the Joe Rogan experience there's an
article in the Atlantic about tracking
you with cell phones and tracking you in
comparison to trusted people that have
tested negative like that that that
could be the way that we could release
people from quarantine and this is we're
gonna go full Eddie Bravo on something
like this dude because if you have to
have something you have to have your
phone on you to travel like apparently
they have to do and I think it's in
China right don't they have their phone
to travel and they have a health app on
their phone but sort of like they have
to keep their health app up-to-date
there's one on every iPhone already yeah
but I think this is a different kind of
it's not you know it's a different kind
of thing that like you have to have like
you have to been certified that you
tested clean for Co vid and then it's on
your phone digital certificate or so
right so yeah yeah something like that
I'm fine with that and that to you can't
be because then they can restrict your
travel just based on whether if you're
sick though but yeah but but here's the
thing we've always just accepted that
people can be sick and we prefer freedom
over a hundred percent safety we've
always accepted they're not doing that
now child we're not doing that now but
my point is we've always accepted that
and if we decide to keep going further
down that rabbit hole where we make
someone carry a device where you can
track their location you have to have a
travel it's scary it gets weird man it
gets weird you have to have a phone and
I have to be able to see what you've
been up to what have you been partying
all night and you go to the airport
they're like I think you have cancer
like none and I just hit coke high blood
pressure go back to see my family please
Denny's yeah I just I'm trying to go
home I want to go home sleeping for
three days yeah and they're like you're
sick we need to quarantine you but this
that's a poor example just for humor but
there's a slippery road if you tell
people they have to have a phone
everywhere they go right now you don't
you could have a driver's license and/or
a passport and you can get on a plane
and
you're fine you don't have to have a
phone you don't have to have a phone
right now and I'm not saying you
shouldn't have a phone but I'm saying if
someone's gonna tell you that you have
to have a phone everywhere you go things
are going to get slippery but what it
was they're gonna be able to track you
100% but what if it's just like like the
way you scan your boarding pass what if
you scan to make sure you're healthy but
that's the problem is this kind of after
that they don't track you look but think
about all Google has done and it's not a
knock on Google but all Google has done
with basically just the information that
they give to companies on what your
activities are right
there's a read the reason why when
you're talking about things and these
Google ads pop up why is that why when
you look up something you find those ads
in everything what's because they're
trying to tell you things right they're
trying to figure out the modern what
you're looking at yeah yeah trying to
figure out what makes you tick why
wouldn't they do that with this - why
wouldn't you do that with this - well I
wouldn't like if they if you can track
people if you could track who's gonna
pay for all that software and all that
stuff like well we'll just put a few ads
up would you rather be quarantined
imagine would you rather be quarantine
but imagine if you could track people if
they could go everywhere and while while
they're doing they're like you know
everything they do you know they went to
this grocery store you know they went to
this house you check it you gave an app
on them that they can't leave behind
they that checks their health it's dicey
it's dicey it's there should never be a
group that has more power over an
individual rather than another
individual it's not like like the thing
about having a massive group that can
tell one person that they can or can't
do something is it can be abused if
everyone is even it can never be abused
if we all follow the same rules in the
same laws then okay we all agree we all
have the same amount of control and
power over each other's lives
but as soon as you have more control
than the person who you're monitoring
then things can get weird it's just
natural people are weird
they control people they like
controlling people they like abusing
power a lot of people that have power
abuse power
so if you give the power of constant
surveillance in exchange for the freedom
to be able to go everywhere you want and
the relieving of quarantine we just want
to know you're healthy no big deal
you're like okay yeah well let yeah if
you let us monitor to you that's what's
going on it's not that they thought this
through and this was their end goal I
don't think so I don't think it's a
[ __ ] conspiracy that's what I know I
think people take advantage of things
that happen right that's more likely
what's more likely as a crazy thing
happens and people automatically take
advantage when they find an opportunity
especially the more predatory amongst us
[Applause]